you used to do you want to say it okay
he's gonna say what he used to call me
when we would we were tour together tiny
towns and then we'd go do colleges
together as stand-ups and you decide if
it's racist or not so why don't you say
it Pete and then we'll let them decide
what is it that you called me we would
drive around in the safety of our
friendship bubble tiny towns in ina
towns Ohio Iowa Iowa and you would I'd
say look Kumail you're the only brown in
town
so what do you guys think racist or
super racist not a segment we're doing
on the show
I've also for many years been pushing
you to say once you go you will you say
this one yeah he's he says one of my
pickup line should be once he go
Pakistan you never go back it's tan it
works it plays okay I tried it once and
I'm married to her so that's right yeah
it worked worked so we have a we have a
good relationship that's why I'm allowed
to be racist
no just cuz you know me doesn't make it
not racist if I didn't know you
it would be super racist but here are we
in an acceptable like alkaline acidity
sort of 7 what is acceptable racism it
feels like it's an oxymoron remember
when you had a unibrow almost no segue
to that I if I had a mustache I would
look like an equal sign
I did can I see it yeah oh yeah hey you
know bride's gone
oh god it's creeping back isn't it oh
you want to see what I can do you can do
the worm with your face yeah it is not a
compliment
hahaha no I think it is